Je suis un zombie cette maladie ne veut pas me laisser en paix
Mais on s'en bat les couilles parce que aujourd'hui les amis on va vivre une nouvelle histoire d'amour
Eh oui vous vous souvenez, il y a quelques années
Quand on a joué à ''Emily Is Away''
C'était un simulateur de... MSN
Où tu parlais à une fille qui s'appelait ''Emily''
Et  années après années, tu voyais la relation qui se s'établissait entre toi et cette fille
Et c'était hyper frustrant parce que...
C'était clairement la meuf de ta vie
Mais tu passais à coté
Ahhhhhhhh... *dégouté*
Chut, soyez pas triste, soyez pas triste
Le 2 vient de sortir
Peut-être cette fois il arrive à sortir avec la meuf de sa vie
*claque des mains*
C'est ce qu'on lui souhaite
OK, chapitre un
Été 2006
Emily, c'est qui Emily ?
''Ma mère dirait que c'est tout le monde.''
''N'importe quelle fille, n'importe quel mec, n'importe quelle personne
que chacun a déjà aimé.''
On commence sur un peu d'émotion
C'est, c'est, ça m'ému, ça m'émeut
Bon, c'que je constate c'est que, c'est le même chat de merde qu'avant, ils ne sont pas passé à facebook ou quoi
On va s'appeller ''Philippe''
Les filles adorent les mecs qui s'appellent ''Philippe''
Et First Name on va s'appeller, heuuuuu...
''Philippos''
Les filles elles adorent les mecs qui ont ''Philippos'' comme nom de famille
On est entrain d'établir notre profil
Plutôt ''chamillionaire'' ou ''arctic monkeys'', ou ''against me'' ?
Plutôt ''arctic monkeys''
OK c'est parti !
''Yoooo Philippos !''
Hey, déjà ''Philippos'' c'est pour les intimes tu m'appelles Philippe s'il te plaît
OK ?
Les gens apprennent la confiance
''Yoooo Evelyn !''
OK, qui est ''Evelyn'' ?
''Je chill, j'allais mettre du vernis sur mes ongles''
''Je n'arrive pas à me décider sur la couleur''
Attends attends attends, parce que si c'est pas ''Emily'', on s'en bat les couilles
Nous on veut juste parler à ''Emily''
''Noir'', ''Cyan'' ou ''je crois en toi'' ?
''Je crois en toi'' bien sûr, elle se sentira soutenue et on gagne des points
Alors, si vous avez des vues sur une fille n'appliquer jamais ce que je dis dans mes vidéos, c'est le pire truc à faire
Haaaa... *dégout*
''Mais c'est un vrai problème !''
''En parlant de couleur, j'aime bien ton nouveau projet''
''Ouais, ça m'a prit du temps''
... J'sais pas de quoi elle parle
''Alors comment s'est passé ton été ?''
Bien ça va bien, t'sais faut pas dire que c'était ennuyant mais faut pas dire que c'était ouf non plus
On se met dans la partie neutre un peu de la réponse tu vois
Encore une fois ne suivez jamais ce conseil
''Cool, qu'est-ce que t'as fait ?''
''Des jeux vidéos'', ''je suis sorti avec mes amis'' ou ''j'ai fait de la romance'' ?
Heeeuu...
''Je suis sorti avec mes amis'', c'est très bien on est un jeune basique, on est classique
''Oh cool cool, j'arrive pas à croire qu'on retourne en cours dans un mois''
''L'école c'est nul'', ''ouais l'école c'est sympa'', ''ah j'ai hâte d'y retourner''
Bon, on va dire que ''l'école c'est normal'', voilà non mais là on est neutre, on est neutre
Mais d'un coup, on va se dissocier mon pote
Comme le film des suricates et tu vas voir ils vont être choqués en face
''Ouais ça peut l'être, comme notre histoire en cours l'année dernière''
*choqué* ⊙o⊙
Mais non, fausse alerte putain
J'ai mal traduit
''Comme notre classe d'histoire, l'année dernière''
*rire*
Ahhh, putain je suis trop chaud là pour tout c'qui est histoire d'amour mon gars je vois de l'amour là ou il y en a pas du tout
Ouais j'lui dit : ''cette classe était cool''
Ah, mais c'est un peu des réponses fermées que je fais, je fais que de valider ce qu'elle dit sans ouvrir de porte c'est un peu nul
Je suis un peu une merde
Je vais peut-être arrêter de draguer les femmes à tout jamais
''Tu devrais sortir avec moi et mes amis des fois''
Carrément, carrément là on répond : "carrément."
''Est-ce que tu as des trucs prévus pour le reste de tes vacances ?''
On va dire "sortir plus"
Comme ça on lui tend une perche, mon pote, comme aç (ça). Une règle 30 cm on lui tend
On veut qu'elle l'attrape et qu'elle nous réponde "Mais viens, viens avec moi pas de souci"
Et qu'elle en fasse une équerre après, comme ça là
C'est énorme ce que je dis
"Moi et mes amis on va faire le warped tour samedi. C'est un festival de musique punk rock"
"C'est quoi ton type de musique préféré ?"
*clin d'oeil*
"Le punk rock, comme toi"
"OOOOOH t'es mon nouveau meilleur ami !"
*Musique désespoir*
Quelqu'un a une corde ?
Nan mais je pense qu'en vrai c'est pas elle la la fille qu'on veut pécho
laissez moi me consoler en me disant ça
"Mec je sais pas où sont mes amis. Ils étaient supposés venir me chercher il y a 30 minutes"
*musique épique*
Est ce que vous voulez voir cette porte s'ouvrir ?
Cette perche se tendre
Tout est sous contrôle faites moi confiance !
"Ils sont probablement morts" moi j'adore le second degré ça me fait beaucoup rire
Le problème c'est que si elle non, on est mort
"Lol t'as sûrement raison. On devait aller chez un ami et faire la fête"
"Et me laisser seul comme ça ?"
Ah mais après ça c'est un peu pot de colle
Ouais mais peut être qu'elle va nous proposer de venir du coup
"T'en fait pas j'ai mon téléphone"
*musique désespoir*
*pleure*
Cette video c'est un coup de couteau permanent dans le coeur quoi
"Je devrais probablement commencer à rassembler mes affaires"
Franchement tu peux me glisser dedans, dans ton sac vite fait
... personne ne verra
On va juste luis dire "tu ne reviens pas ce soir ?"
"je sais pas je vais peut être dormir là bas on va voir"
"Oh il faudrait que j'amène un film
tu veux m'aider à le choisir ?"
Non mais attends
non mais là mec c'est plus la friendzone, là, mec !
Là c'est l'armée... l'armée de l'amitié quoi
Non mais vraiment !
On lui tend des perches mon gars...
...monumentales !
Jamais elle nous propose de venir !
Et par contre choisir le film
devant lequel elle va emballer son mec
Là il y pas de problèmes hein
Putain !
On va choisir le pire film où c'est vraiment pas propice à embrasser quelqu'un
Genre "Le Livre De La Jungle mon gars
"Destination Final 3 ou The Descent"
Attend mais très bonne idée, ça, des trucs "gores"
Mais nan c'est pareil
*imitation voix de fille* AH ! Ça m’écœure rassure moi
Putain ! On est baisé
Ouais mais "The Descent" c'est trop horreur
Donc on va dire "Final Destination"
Quelle type de film t'adore ?
"Action , Comédie , Horreur"
Moi j'adore L'Horreur
Mais elle proposé 2 trucs d'horreur
Ça peut être pas mal de dire "Horreur"
Ouais mais nan mais elle va me mettre encore plus dans la case
"Oh meilleur ami ! Tu penses comme moi !"
OH !
"Moi aussi c'est mes films préférés on devrait s'en mater un ensemble, un de ces quatre"
Ouuuh
Un de ces deux même... Tout de suite, ALLER !
"Par contre je crie." Aller c'est marrant "par contre je crie"
Faut la faire rire un petit peu
Comme on dit femme qui rire égal femme qui te dit : "t'es mon meilleur ami"
AHAHAH *rires*
Et oui les amis
Hey , je viens d'avoir un texto
Me dis pas que tes ami sont là
"Ils seront bientôt là"
Putain nan elle nous échappe elle nous file entre les doigts elle passe entre les mailles du filet
On va dire "ils sont pas morts" c'est marrant
Tu sais on fait genre qu'on s'en bat les couilles qu'elle soit en soirée sans nous
Il faut toujours faire ça de toutes façon avec les filles
Il faut faire genre que tu t'en bat les couilles alors que çà te CASSE les couilles
Bon elle nous a pas répondu, mais on eu un message de emerz35
C'est pas Emily elle justement ?
"Comment ça va ?"
"Je chill"
Oh putain Eva nous a parlé
"Ouais il sont pas mort xD"
Ils sont en retard car Steve était allé acheter de l'alcool
Qui est Steve ?
On va juste dire "eh je le connais ?"
C'est mieux ça passe bien. Ca passe mieux que "qui est Steve?"
Oh putain c'est une conversation croiseé
Y'a emerz35  qui nous a redit un truc
"Je chill aussi"
"Alors t'as fait un truc cool aujourd'hui ?"
EUUUHHHHH
Je suis sortit avec mes amis
Il ment c'mytho. Il ment c'myto il faut bien faire genre qu'on a une vie
Et qu'il y a d'autre filles qui tournent autour de nous
Ok du coup c'est Eva qui nous a répondu
"Steve Myers, il a eu son diplôme l'année dernière"
Il seulement 20 ans mais il a une fausse carte d'identité
Ah oui parce que l'accol c'est 21ans au Etats-Unis
Du coup c'est emerz35  qui nous répond
"Cool que c'est que vous avez fait ?"
Ah oui c'est vrai que je lui avais dit qu'on était sorti avec des amis
Putain la conversation croisée elle terrible !
Moi j'ai passé la matinée à jouer au jeux vidéos
COOL
"On aurait dû jouer ensemble"
C'est très bien ça. Petite réponse bien... ça montre que nous aussi on joue au jeu vidéo
On est bien x3
J'ai joué au Sims 2 je suis accro a ce jeu ah ah
One eternyty later
Ah ah ouais
Très bon choix o n lui répond juste très bon choix
Sobre on fait pas le myto elle se doute que si on dit que je susi fan elle fait faire HIENN EUHH
Ok Eva (punk4eva) putain la conversation croisée ca me pète le crane la
J'ai besoin de truc a faire
AHHH
On va lui dire,on pourait fiare un truc
J'aime bien pas trop motrer qu'on est intéressé tu vois
Tu vois ce que je veut dire bien sur que tu vois
Toi qui a pécho 600 filles alors que tu est qu'en 6ème HEIN
Ouais on pourrait genre sortir juste nous deux
OUUUAAAAIIIISSSS
Ouais juste nous
Va s-y la je rentre dedans bien
Ouais juste no...
MAIS NAN x2
Il avait écrit ouias juste nous deux
Il a effacer pour marquer comme tu veut
MAIS NANNNN MEC T'ES TROP CON
Juste nous deux ça va me va en plus on aime tout les deux les filmes d'horreur
On se voit week-end prochain
OHOHLALALALALA
IL VA DORMIR A LA MAISOOOOON
Ok c'est fini avec Eva (punk4eva)
J'espere juste que ce week-end il va rien se passer avec ces amis de merde
Putain c'est bon on peut se consentré sur la conversaition de emerz35
*Musique
Reston ami ok ?
(OHOHLALA la double FriendZone apres avoir vu ca on peut mourir tranquille)
Une fisselle un truc pour me pendre
La c'est la Double FriendZone en l'espace 20 minutes je ......
*pleure fffff
OHHHHH
On va répondre on vera en mode ça se trouve j'ai pas envie qu'on reste ami
Hey, tu connais le groupe qui s'apelle "Snow Partol"
Ah la chanson "Chasing Cars"
Enorme
J'aimerai telement le voir en concert mais bon il y a jamais aucan groupe qui vient jouer par ici
Totalement vrai tout ce qu'on a c'est genre le "Warpet Tour"
Ah ba c'est le truc ou il y a euhh.. Eva (punk4eva)
Acctuellement en train de pecho un autre mec
Ah ouais c'est le festival de "music punk" tu connais quelq'un qui est  aller
Ne jamais mentir
Il ne faut jamais mentir
Ouais de ami
C'est un myto
Hey , finalement t'a mis a joue "bio"
"atcitc monkeys" moi aussi il dont dans mes info
OHHHHHH
Donc t'es ma persone préféré maintenant
C'est pas mal ça
On est bien la x2
Jeff veut qu'on sorte ensemble ce week-end mais j'ai telllement pas envie
Putain quand une fille de te dis ça je sais pas pourquoi mais ça sent bon ça sent la rose quoi
Dans ta chambre t'es la t'es ahhhhhh
Mais quelle perche collosale !
Stupide Jeff on répond c'est très bien ça
Stupide Jeff et ses stupide amis
OHH LA  c'est un peu violent
AH AH  ils sont pas aussi térible
Mais sortir avec eux c'est juste dire trainer et etre bourré
Oh c'est nul
J'ai répondu direct oh c'est nul
Du coup j'ai paniqué j'ai dit que j'avais deja un truc de prévu
Mais tu n'a rien de prévu on lui répond
Et la les amis on touche au but
Oh que non ah ah il faut que je trouve un truc a faire demain
On n'a rien prévu
Ah c'est bien ça j'aime bien ça cette réponse la
On rien prévu on pourait... jouer au jeux vidéo tout les deux
NANNNNNNNN (tres viril) MAIS NNAAAAAANNNNNNN
C'est la cata
Il y a dit oh on a rien de prévu on pourait ....jouer a des jeux vidéo tout les deux
Nan mais nan nan nan
C'est avec ta meilleur tu joue jeux vidéo
Hmm pourquoi pas est ce-que on devrait inviter d'autre gens
Nan alors tu refait pas la meme erreur que tout ta l'heure Philpos je te le dit
Il corige et il met je m'en fou comme tu veut
CLAP Bonjour
Il me Il me vener Philipos il me vener
Peut-importe on aime pas les meme jeux peut-etre qu'on devait inviter d'autres gens et faire autre chose de jouer au jeux vidéo
Putain Philipos t'a niqué le game mon gars t'es nul
Okay pourquoi pas
Oh il se fait tard
Ouais bon c'est fini quoi en gros elle va dormir elle va dormir on en parle plus
Elle déco
On déco aussi
Au putain
Et voila les amis c'est déja la fin de cette première vidéo sur Emily is Aways 2
Putain mec tu sens le triangle amoureux chelou la qui arrive tu sens ou pas
Machin est amoureux de nous nous on est amoureux de machin nan nan n'importe quoi (FAIL Merci pour l'auteur des sous-tritres)
Je sens qu'il faloire géré parce que sinon mec on va se prendre une double friendzone deja la on s'en prit une double friendzone a l'heure actuelle maintenant la
La je peut te dire je l'ai atravers la gorge mon gars
Beurk
Le StalioBoos
Et bah les amis je pense qu'il aura encore une deux trois vidéo sur ce jeu je trouve qu'il est trop bien au niveau du sénario
Les dialogues sont hyper réaliste et et putain on a envie de sortir avec l'une des filles quoi
La on a 2 profils diférents qui aime faire des tourneés avec ces pote et se bourrer la guele (Eva)
L'autre qui est plutôt introvertit qui joue jeu vidéo qui aime pas trop sortir et boir (Emily)
Je me demande vers qui on va y aller et comment ça va se passer
Et je susi sur que les deux filles vont ce parle entre elles
ENfin... Bref x3
Je me fait des films dans ma tête putain ça va pas du tout
Allez je vous dit a tres vite pour une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien pourquoi je fait cette outro a genoux
On s'en pas
Au revoir
Que va t-il se passer avec Emily et Eva est ce que Squeezie va t-il arriver a ce plus prendre des "Double FriendZone en l'espace de 20 minutes Abonne toi a Squeezie